hey how you doing today
grateful thank you what's your name
where you from Pharrell
um my name is Pharrell Williams I'm from
Virginia Beach Virginia absolutely dude
Pharrell always has the worst glasses on
that it's like unbelievable he'll be
wearing like little condom rings with
twisty ties attached to him and he's
just like
you look bad um VA is definitely in the
house I'll play with him for real we see
you looking describe your fit for us
today oh it's that thing oh uh
um human race hoodie okay how much has
Pharrell had sex with seven women from
Italy
and here and he says stuff like I don't
like when it's too wet down there
uh-huh
[Music]
doodles
yeah the Tiffany Watchers
okay boy talking a little boy vomited on
my hat
my Tiffany accessories oh I mean God is
oh I mean the guy dude God is great God
is yes absolutely you give anybody a
styling tip what would it be wait wait
wait wait wait okay sorry about that
wow he looks all he looks truly awful
you know
you look just truly atrocious oh if you
had your friends over and you're like my
friends come in and he dressed up you'd
be like oh no this [__] guy okay okay
okay if you give anybody a stalington
what would it be
transport into the future to save the
world
that's good that's good what makes you
feel happy that's good
Claudio party like what are you what
you're wearing is also your energy your
vibration there you go oh I do not like
when people start talking about
vibrations dude when the second people
talk about vibrations I am for real out
when people talk about low versus high
vibrations I go oh you know what dude
this is actually been really great I'm
gonna bounce because you don't want me
to start hating
okay it's like when people just buy
things and put it on you can tell what
they really feel in their heart versus
what their mind told them was gonna get
the look
I mean the guy dude damn do damn
you could tell when people buy things
and just put them on versus you know
buying them because they really feel
that damn
dude the two biggest idiots that have
ever spoken to each other
I just feel that you can sense that yeah
it's a feeling yes yeah it's be you okay
you know what I'm saying and you know
last but not least like you know
you gotta think about others bro I mean
do you and think about last but I gave
one example and then to last but not
least the guy is on another planet
a planet that [__] is not even out
yet
uh
uh but he's cool I think you know he's
cool I I know obviously jokes dude no
hate guys [__]
that's a cool dude
but also the Watchers
[Music]